[Musik]
manche kommen
die zähne zeigen
als pionier für wieder beleidigt von
landschaft oder abgeschrieben worden
sind
christoph henkel hat eine vision er will
der welt zeigen dass der mensch nicht
nur das potenzial hat die natur zu
zerstören
er kann hier auch helfen sich zu erholen
indem er ihre selbstheilungskräfte
aktiviert
[Musik]
henkel habe vor 30 jahren im
australischen outback eine farm namens
chang aufgebaut fast eine flugstunde
entfernt von einem städtchen namens
kanada
hier trat er wie hier dann über sein
land
das klingt banal aber der effekt ist
unglaublich in wüsten endliche
landschaften kehrt das leben zurück der
mensch bringt das 4 und sein wissen die
natur den regeln und die sonne so kommen
wie man sozusagen miteinander ins
geschäft und alle profitieren dass die
natur also ist es ökologisch kapital
alle mit mir dass thaksin kommen circa
zwölf stunden tag
es macht also sinn dass man das nie
kommen wie baut das kapital und stockt
und lehrt für die zinsen als status mir
einfach mit dieser technologie raubbau
krieg der substanz henkel neigt zu einem
wolkigen tuk tuks seine resultate sind
indes handfest
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
henkel hat sich und seine familie in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten einiges
zugemutet um der welt zu zeigen was
möglich ist wenn mensch und natur
zusammenarbeiten
[Musik]
jacqueline henkel hat ihrem mann
geholfen die fahr mitten im nirgendwo
aufzubauen und dafür auf viele
annehmlichkeiten verzichtet
für mich persönlich ich verspüre nicht
wirklich passion fürs land also ich das
gefühl es ist wichtig was er macht und
ich drücke thema unterstütze aber mini
passion sind manche ich bin ich
hoffentlich viel lieber mit menschen
zusammen
sie wuchs in guten verhältnissen auf der
vater war hoteldirektor in engelberg und
konnte bis zu seinem tod nicht wirklich
verstehen wieso seine tochter die
schweiz verließ um ihr leben freiwillig
unter so prekären bedingungen zu
verbringen
gestrandet in der australischen 1
[Musik]
die umfangreiche hausapotheke der
händler schluss regelmäßig überprüft
werden
wenn medikamente vielen oder abgelaufen
sind kann das tödlich sein
der nächste arzt ist mehr als eine
flugstunde weiter entfernt und trotzdem
hat die gelernte kinderkrankenschwester
sich entschieden hier drei kinder groß
zu ziehen
ich habe ich gestoppt erklärt ich bin
verliebt sich die jungs ich bin aber
lustig sie und ich habe mir das
vorstelle irgendwo absieht besucht
also ich habe wirklich ich eigentlich
sehr wenig probleme sehe will ich glaube
jugend hilft
[Musik]
das australische fernsehen hat die
schweizer familie im outback schon
mehrmals besucht henkels resultate
beeindruckende australier die
lebensumstände faszinieren
[Musik]
julians zu kommunizieren denn du kannst
nicht einfach weglaufen du musst deine
probleme lösen
eine art rosamunde pilcher stoff der
allerdings nicht an den küsten süd
england spielt sondern im australischen
busch
[Musik]
jacqueline henkel er verbringt noch
immer viel zeit mit ihrem mann
sie genießt in eigenen garten die ruhe
und die natur ist aber mittlerweile auch
mehrere monate pro jahr abwesend sie hat
sich zur sozialarbeiterin ausbilden
lassen und in der stadt ein
teilzeitpensum in der
kinderschutzbehörde angenommen
[Musik]
aus die eigenen kinder ausgeflogen
zeigen habe sie eine neue
herausforderung gesucht
zudem sei sie ein mensch der gerne unter
menschen sein
ich glaube das ist schwierig sieht
isolation der user und plötzlich zu
realisieren war
ich bin wirklich allein damit bestehen
das ist sehr isoliert ich glaube das ist
schwierig sie unter nachher aber auf der
anderen seite ich bin ein mensch ich bin
voller tour ruft ich weiß ein jeder
mensch und ich auch sehr gerne routine
und ich glaube zu bauruinen hier bisher
einbringen und gut schlafen und ich bin
naturverbunden und das hat mir gefallen
also ich denke dann ist das eigentlich
kann ich das gar keiner kaputt mitdenken
in ungarn und christoph henkel konnte
sich seinen ruf mit dem studium der
schöpfung
er wuchs auf einer farm in rhodesien auf
dem heutigen simbabwe als das land
anfang der 1970 er jahre im bürgerkrieg
versank kehrten die henkels in die
schweiz zurück wo christoph seine
heutige frau traf er wanderte nach
australien aus und sie folgte ihm
die beiden gründeten eine familie
christoph henkel wollte pharma sein und
die natur verstehen lernen darum führte
er seine liebsten anfang der 1990 er
jahre an einen ort wo es monatelangen
dauerregen gibt und wo es über 40 grad
im schatten heiß werden kann
das hat im moment ganz klar um im
nachhinein hatte das hier erwartet die
sicher frau der unternehmen und und dass
sie das mussten auch was er gemacht hat
und ich bin dankbar dass das eben das
leben miteinander können lacht der sache
und das ausführen mit den anderen das
miteinander auch eine reise zwischen
ihnen also bin ich sehr lange
[Musik]
jetzt wo alle von klimawandel und
umweltschutz reden könnte henkels
feldforschung zukunftsweisend sein
der graf für mich dass das ergebnis so
nämlich dass er bewusstlos wird bis juli
jetzt habe das ganze jahr - und mehr
wasserversorger computer haben überhaupt
saft welche fließen wieder tiere sind da
um pflanzen wachsen
kurz das leben ist zurückgekehrt seien
gezielt brisanz haben wir das einreichen
einer breite grad
die keine bedingungen herrschen und das
ist dann sah ich die richtige richtung
geht das meiste passiert vorlage muss
aber nur zwischen ihnen jetzt die nach
hause aber die erste stützen aber
wichtig dass wir diese aufstellungs
prozess aktiv begleitet werden
mit einer moment auch die nacht gebiete
die henkels haben ein simples aber
effektives system entwickelt sie zeigen
mir wie alles anfängt
sie bringen viel hier dann auf irland
und lassen sie dort in einem
ausgeklügelten rhythmus zirkulieren
die tiere sollen also wieder milch geben
noch später gegessen werden
sie sind vielmehr eine art
landschaftsgärtner
[Musik]
es geht primär darum dass sie im
vorderbau dafür denn das macht sie denn
das sicher dass dort die material- oder
das abgestandene zustoße durch debatte
dass wenn feuchtigkeit um eine
staatsreform und wenn bodenfeuchtigkeit
minister wurde feuchtigkeit länger
beliebt
die tiere lagen mit ihren hufen den
boden auftritten pflanzen und deren
samen runter und düngen das land mit
ihren experimenten der boden beginnt
wieder zu leben
sonne und regen unterstützen die
positive dynamik
zuerst braucht es also die großtiere
dann kommen die pflanzen zurück und
schließlich das wasser das von den
beliebten böden wieder gespeichert
werden kann
henkel hat prinzipien entwickelt die
globale gültigkeit haben
bissig biodiversität fördern lässt die
wassersicherheit steigt und das land
gesünder und produktiver wird
gleichzeitig binden diese landschaften
tonnenweise kohlenstoff kurz henkel hat
entdeckt wie sich positive entwicklungen
einleiten lassen
bush forcierten seit jahrhunderten das
gegenteil teilweise einfach durch
menschen teilweise durch blitzschläge
und ähnliches zerstören sie ganze
landstriche
wir sind eine art natürlicher feind für
henkels arbeit
er versucht das wiederbelebte land durch
brandschneisen zu schützen
breite streifen die das feuer daran
hindern sollen sich auszubreiten
sein sohn bobby ist gekommen um ihn zu
unterstützen
zunächst wird der boden rund um das
gebiet befeuchtet das abgebrannt werden
soll
das vorher so keine chance haben außer
kontrolle zu geraten
[Applaus]
sie nutzen brandrodung um hier später
kies gewinnen zu können
gleichzeitig entstehen so brandschneisen
was ich jetzt halt sehr kontrolliert
also die für wenn wir sie kennen den ort
und brauchen sich also vorbereitet
eigentlich sind einfach ein blitzschlag
ein oder andy also im oktober
später im jahr wenn die große für
jugendliche mit mehreren tagen ja das
ist einfach teil - oder wenn es so
einfach wäre
[Musik]
fast die hälfte auf einer kleinen fläche
kontrolliert gemacht haben passiert
jedes jahr auf tausende von
quadratkilometern unkontrolliert mit
verheerenden folgen der boden ist der
sonne nun schutzlos ausgeliefert und wie
versiegelt henkel simuliert was in der
regenzeit passiert das wasser kann nicht
mehr in den boden eindringen es fließt
einfach ab eine negative dynamik beginnt
ich meinte dass mir das sicher ein
australier setzt eigentlich bahnbrechend
sie pionierarbeit was es braucht ein
stück wo menschen nicht mehr existieren
wird es regenerieren und die erde aber
die ökologische ist los bringen
[Musik]
die handballer des kürzlich vater
geworden seine frau nadja stammt aus
perth seit einigen jahren leben die
beiden in kanada eine knappe flugstunde
von der form der henker entfernen hobby
möchte seinen wohnsitz allerdings ball
hierher verlegen seine tochter georgia
soll auf kucera groß wird
so wie wenn man das eigentlich als
junger rufen auch sie mit dem du musst
die tour eigentlich regel sehr viel
automatisch laienorganisationen das ist
ihnen genauso wenig in die muttersprache
die muttersprache auf welchen weg wir
täglich oder das ist und einfach mit
also und das ist glaube ich auch immer
wieder der natur verbringt und das war
so und gemüse oder kirsche oder spiele
schauen diese auch so wie glaubst die
ziemlich schnell die großstadt oder
künstliche welt ziemlich schnell
vergessen werden
herr
[Musik]
es sei eine kindheit voller abenteuer
und freiheit gewesen erinnert sich bobby
mit einem großen wunderland direkt vor
der haustür
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die schule von zu hause statt
eine lehrerin unterrichtete ihn und
andere kinder aus dem busch via funk
es könnte ziemlich einsam
ja definitiv aber mit dem flugzeug
dauert es ja nur eine knappe stunde bis
in die stadt
und dort haben wir viele freunde wenn
wir die nicht hätten wäre es hier
schwierig internet und eine
telefonverbindung
das macht das ganze viel einfacher hobby
möchte zusammen mit seiner frau und aus
weiterführen was seine eltern aufgebaut
haben und es irgendwann an die nächste
generation übergeben
es werden dass tropfen ich hätte mich
als worte dass die nicht hindert aber
was du machst du nun was die erfreut bin
ich glaube ich glaube dass uns wieder
genau auf dass die kinder das größte ist
wenn sich center sich das klasse die
händler sind weitgehend selbst versorgen
was nicht hier wächst kaufen sie einmal
pro monat in der stadt dahin
aber jetzt haben sie gast des
regenwassers sonst
[Musik]
macht euch die welt untertan mich heißt
das nur zu dem was ich da heißt nicht
dass die gewaltigen und einfach nun muss
nicht was sie können 18 im sternen
[Musik]
der glaube spielt eine große rolle nicht
glauben
gerade am anfang wenn ich ein gewisses
vita und und mir sorgen gemacht habe
kann ich mir auch immer wieder zeit ich
bin eigentlich einfach vertrauen auf
gott und und wenn das niveau ist ein
auto wenn das soweit ist und wenn das so
klappen wird das irgendwie egal und ich
glaube dass das frauen eigentlich eine
höhere macht wo ein vielleicht im
richtigen moment sich auf ca das hat mir
auf jeden fall kaufen
[Musik]
ich habe mir am anfang nahm ist wo die
schwierige zeit
sie sind und ich meine schönheit
wirklich haben wir solche daraus habe
ich mir der name ist sagt du musst
wirklich versuchen also eigentlich
versuche die schöne sache knies und und
audi zieht nach oben und unten herrscht
irgendwie ein wahres wo war eigentlich
schön ist
[Musik]
ich habe immer schon gern eigentlich in
wälder und mini welle und ich kann als
das wenn ein kind habe ich eigentlich
nicht in der website geschaffen oder
karriere machen also vor dem ist es für
mich im sinne des opfers sie wird sie
uns oft bringen
und wenn ich jetzt zurückdenke dann
gesehen ich das ende auf das privileg
dass ich ein ort voller liebe wo viele
leute unbekanntes
[Musik]
in einer phase wo man gesagt platz
machen für die nächste generation
einfach nur dass man sich nicht
möglichkeiten der verbraucher für die
nächste generation seine beiden töchter
kommen gerne zu besuch möchten aber
nicht auf gott schorno lieben darum
übergibt der gefahren war seinem sohn
der senior und seine frau bleiben aber
hier wohnen 20 uhr ist wirklich sehr
verschiedene generationen platz sind
sich einig dass man ständig noch nicht
dafür ist mit rampen bobby henkel ist
selbstständig er hat einen
ein-mann-betrieb aus flugzeug und
helikopter mechaniker aufgebaut
wenn ich jetzt werden gerne nachsagt
würden wir uns ja auch verrückt und
befriedigung oder tätig das machen das
in sieben jahren mit wenig klebe ich
lebe ja bz ich sehe noch hundertfach
langsam vorwärts
sein vater hat als junggeselle geld
zusammengespart und in der stadt in
immobilien investiert
die familie lebte von den mieteinnahmen
die fahren private jahre ein
herzensprojekt dass sich nicht rentieren
musste bobby sucht nun nach wegen damit
auch geld zu verdienen eines einer
ritalin ist öko tourismus eine andere
sind co2 zertifikate
[Musik]
dass der traum der henkel es weitergeht
braucht es nicht nur neue köpfe sondern
auch neue visionen
familie danke dass sie gekommen
[Musik]
es soll eines der letzten male werden
dass bobby und seine frau katja
verlassen
bald schon werden sie bleiben und sie
beginnen ein neues kapitel zu schreiben
christoph henkel wurde der natur ein
leben lang gutes tun
das soll so bleiben über den tod hinaus
sein körper soll dereinst zu dünger
werden wenn die vorstellung ist dass er
teilweise schönes juli mache und dass
deren es mich hier legte mit der
spitzhacke und oder grasl 7 und auch den
stein einfach sagt durch ja auch eine
aber den greift auch die natur nicht zu
kann aber schon weil ich irgendwie es
war schon immer klar wenn dinge ist ein
mitmach nächte werden
ein anderer stelle dass das sind
verwirklicht gebauten endlich konsequent
zurück
[Musik]